[Applaudissements]
houba bien sûr c'est surtout voilà il y
aura des questions sur tout mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu cette affaire boubacar
hills
voilà on se rappelle gilles on vous a
fait un petit résumé toute la sphère
orly aujourd'hui en passant par les
nombreux rebondissements sur le lieu où
voilà le voeu que le fameux combat
pourrait avoir lieu
on en parle juste après avec vous
regarde nous sommes le 1er août dernier
à l'aéroport d'orly en plein après midi
une bagarre éclate entre les rappeur
booba et carris qui devaient tous les
deux se rendre à barcelone pour des
concerts sur les images coups de poing
coups de bouteille de parfum et décrit
des témoins de la scène choqués
[Applaudissements]
en quelques secondes les vidéos font le
tour des réseaux sociaux puis des
chaînes de télévision violente rixe
survenue à l'air au porto lyon bagarre à
orly entre les doigts par s'appelle
booba et carris booba et carris et leurs
entourages respectifs intercepté par les
forces de l'ordre trois jours plus tard
les deux hommes sont conduits en
détention provisoire en attendant d'être
jugé le 9 octobre dernier les deux
hommes ont finalement été condamné à 18
mois de prison avec sursis et 50000
euros d'amande et ne comptez pas sur
boubacar hills pour enterrer la hache de
guerre histoire d'en finir pour de bon
avec ce conflit et enfin désigné un
grand vainqueur le 25 décembre dernier
booba postes sur instagram un message
adressé à son ennemi lui proposant un
affrontement sans règle en mma dans un
octogone dans l'octogone son rêve c'est
quand tu veux vrai depuis les deux
hommes peinent à se mettre d'accord pour
demander un contrat avec leurs jours vos
potes à recevoir demain alors qu'à
plusieurs reprises des dates et des
lieux ont été adoptés en france
pendant en belgique puis en tunisie
tunisie c'était le meilleur compromis
la tunisie ça va pas le faire frères les
différents rendez-vous ont été reportés
ou annulés
des contrats ont failli être signés mais
rien n'est encore décidé ce soir en
direct dans tpm p booba répond à toutes
vos questions
[Applaudissements]
alors on a plein de questions pour toi
ou battues répondent à toutes les
questions
on dort on attend alors il ya que si mme
kenny d'abord crétine baby do et
concrètement partie le clash la brouille
avec cary ça oui c'est une longue
histoire mais le vrai commencement c'est
il a fait un freestyle à skyrock flash
est ouvertement sans dire non mais ça
m'était destinée est là parce que avant
tu de cette mine de rien vous aimiez
bien parce qu'on a fait on a fait une
petite vidéo récap aussi de vos
relations avons émis nos reins avant
c'est vrai que c'est aux danois
patroller à la cei a pas de problème
après j'ai appris à le connaître je vais
pas trop apprécié et déçue elle a été
déçue mais il vous a blessé en fait
c'est ça c'est parce qu'il vous a blessé
dans ce fameux freestyle blessé va
clasher ouattara n'a pas accepté non
voilà c'est dit voilà c'est un pote un
pote king qui me classe voilà c'est
inacceptable c'est qu'on lui c'est comme
ça qu'a appris l'histoire pour bernard
montiel ex rebelle a tiré qu'à prier ces
mots pas le
entre booba et carris ça n'a pas
toujours été la guerre les deux hommes
ont même été très proches au début des
années 2010 alors que booba était déjà
le roi du rap
il épaule caris jeunes rappeurs inconnu
ensemble ils enregistrent deux titres
criminels ligue et kalach
les caisses
mais alors que tout semble aller pour le
mieux l'histoire s'assombrit lorsque
vous bat reproche à charisme de ne pas
l'avoir soutenu publiquement dans son
clash qui l'opposait au rappeur rohff
le rappeur originaire de boulogne aurait
également mal digéré cette phrase
prononcée par son poulain lors d'un
freestyle sur la radio skyrock
[Musique]
bref en quelques années boubakary sont
pas ses deux frères de sons à frères de
sang on l'a bien résumé ou pas
ouais pas mal ouais c'est endemol c'est
clair gilles verdez combat est ce que
vous regrettez la bagarre d'orly non
sincèrement même regrette de ne pas
l'avoir massacré ce qu'il courait vite
je regrette pas il n'y a pas eu de
personne n'a été blessé enfin on a été
blessé donc je vous n'êtes pas d'accord
c'est rester entre nous il ya eu un peu
de casse c'est une bonne gueule tu t'es
pas dire après voulait pas dire après
ouais j'aurais peut-être pu blesser je
passais par là j'aurais regretté voilà
c'est ça ouais mais là la torah exercice
est rien passé personne a été blessée et
elle a eu peur à un moment quand tu
étais quand tu as été entendu par la
police tout ça ou pas du tout est dit je
vais rester longtemps au pas dit non non
c'est une bagarre c'est une bagarre ça a
fait beaucoup de rues parce que c'est un
bf mais à la sortie du parc y en a tous
les jours
question vous venez ça on voit la
réponse très bien
voyez équivoque oui tranquille face en
cui quand je vois abou bakr je le
regarde je me dis le mec il a la classe
ouais comme toi oui j'aimerais tellement
que tu la cultive
d'ailleurs c'est ça que j'aime ouais
mais tu là que tu la cultive et que tu
puisses il a pris pour un jardinier
manar son séduire davantage mais tout en
restant tout même quand on reste le soi
même ses traits à plonger zouk
alors on a quelqu'un au téléphone c'est
brahim au téléphone tu opposes inquiet
sur grâce à lui brahim bonjour prime ça
va bien brahim avec toi ça va et toi tu
nous appelles doux
d'accord tu fais quoi dans la vie
non pas la fine sinon c'est pas dans la
téléphonie en tout cas tu nous appelles
tu es dans un bunker où quoi en tentant
par weight on est choqué et a pas de
jean michel maire n'dohi lahore les
offres à une question pour booba vas-y
mon brahim qui l'a frappé et il ya pas
mal de choses qu'il pense ou les blagues
et keita on veut savoir s'entourer pas
impactés par tous à ce que sa famille
auraient été impactés par mois les
clashs que tu as eue avec non non non
alors ça m'a fait rire bah c'est vrai
non merci à la fin ça a fait rien ouais
jolie somme qu'à ses coûts il faut y
aller donc la kaaba c'est ce qu'on va
retenir comme ce fut le cas merci brahim
et on t'envoie un téléphone envoie sa
jean-michel j'ai eu je connais pas mal
de potes qu'on est les embrouilles comme
ça et quand c'est aussi sévère que ça
aussi puissant que ça je vais savoir si
au final n'y a pas une histoire de meuf
entre vous deux pour que ça soit vers un
procès verbal histoire de meuf entre
vous deux non non tu ressors pas les
boeufs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah oui madame
oui j'aimerais savoir pourquoi tu n'as
pas signer ce fameux contrat pour le
combat en tunisie parce que c'était un
contrat déjà le contrat qui m'a qui nous
a envoyé ce n'est pas le contrat que lui
assigne et il apparaissait pas sur le
contrat ceux qui l'organisent c'est un
truc de touristes
rien à voir avec ils ont jamais organisé
un truc de mma tunisie c'est beaucoup
trop loin
le but du jeu c'est que tout le monde
puisse y assister quand même c'est un
show même si on s'est bagarré c'est un
show et voilà danemark et booba et
l'autre artiste ne sont mêmes pas écrit
sur le sur le contrat alors la magie sur
un sna là dessus regardez ça va arriver
c'est en train de caler ça va en régie
merci laisse tomber oui vous n'avez pas
envie de vous mettre tous les deux
autour d'une table et de discuter plutôt
que de vous battre
peut-être peut-être que oui il ya des
malentendus de parts et d'autres de vous
dire on a passé le choc avec la bagarre
et ya plein de gens booba qui disent pro
vous mettez pas dans un ring et vous
faites un clash de van nhon ya plein de
gens qui disent ça parce qu'il ya plein
de gens sur twitter qu'ils disent mais
qu'est ce tu leur réponds c'est un
moteur espace ouais ouais ça t'intéresse
pas non pourquoi
ouais non le frappez moi commencé par
une bagarre autour d'une table non mais
à la rigueur pour moi ce sont des tables
à son blog
non mes meilleures amies meilleur ennemi
puisque tu vas y à faty max qui dit
pourquoi ne regrette ni style pas une
combine battle combat de mots plutôt
qu'un combat physique
qu'est ce tu réponds booba je te dis
tout parce qu'elle a beaucoup de gens
aussi sur twitter qu'ils disent oui mais
ce n'est pas un bon exemple pour la
jeunesse que tu es un exemple tout le
monde te suis qu'est ce que tu dis ah ça
c'est juste un combat de boxe
voilà donc c'est pour ça donc tu veux
faire combat c'est y avait eu fc les
mecs qui ce massacre
tu pourrais l'hôpital jamais tu veux ça
reste du sport tu préfères mal à faire
ça dans un cadre de sport plutôt moins
c'est un show voilà c'est vrai c'est un
mot c'est du sport
d'accord alors
s'ils jouent au tennis je leur ai
proposé une partie de tennis mais je
ponds tu pour n'être je peux perdre
alors oui la bataille d'éloquence mal
alors c'est bien mais quel est le
dernier message que vous envoyer carey
sur votre portable vous en êtes rester
ou non je ne me souviens pas ouais ça
oui je pouvais y a qu à risque a déclaré
dans la presse que j'étais obnubilé par
lui confier une fixette sur lui est-ce
que vous rêvez de crise la nuit non je
ne rêve pas la nuit
non mais tu dors jamais taux de façon
voilà alors lui si vous le dis c'est un
ouf
ce mec là ne dort jamais pouvez
l'appeler un homme - quelle heure il
répond tout le temps ouais comme moi en
fait on s'est retrouvé en fait les deux
basques m'appelle et me dit tu dors
poste la peine une étude en panne que tu
dors jamais tu travailles tu suces
d'hommes paraît plus rapidement when
there as mais il faut travailler après
tour dehors après tueur travail c'est ça
hein pas le choix alors booba on va
revenir sur le sur ce combat sur
l'historique ce qui est beaucoup de
tenues beaucoup de changements il ya
beaucoup d'annoncés d'abord vous avez
voulu organiser le combat a lieu aréna
paris sûr que le mma est interdite en
france
c'était pas possible c'est la première
techniques d'esquivé voilà donc ça ce
n'est pas possible
ensuite vous êtes vous avez cherchiez
aller en belgique mais carisse a refusé
la belgique et ça donc nous n'avons
moyens contre un vrai contrat signé
d'accord après charisme lui a trouvé un
accord pour se battre en tunisie chat ne
vous convenait pas donc là aujourd'hui
vous proposez vous la suisse c'est ça
alors un organisateur qui est prêt à le
faire en suisse c'est une grosse
organisation
ils ont un horizon ils ont fait des
boxeurs du fc chez eux c'est très
professionnel
ouais c'est pas loin d'accord donc un
bon nom compliqué ce que tu viens
proposer
est-ce que tu l'a proposé ça car
histoire oui bien sûr exki l'ady gil a
dit qu il avait signé un contrat avec la
tunisie et que c'est là bas que ça doit
se faire cela parce que bhl a pour
l'instant pas de vous toucher aucun
effort en tout cas aucun effort pour que
ça se passe
moi je veux proposer belgique suisse
luxembourg n'importe quoi tu as fais le
je lui ai même dit que j'allais à sevran
s'il voulait si on fait pieds poings et
que c'est faisable en france d'accord
aucun espoir il est restée sur la
tunisie les blocs et pour moi il faut
pas le faire qu'est ce qui justifie
avant qu'on fasse rentrer parce qu'il ya
l'organisateur qui va rentrer et qui va
tout nous expliquer et puis on va voir
dixon qui est très très fort en live
juste vous vous diriez quoi vous dit
quoi sur cette affaire teint doc gynéco
tu dis quoi toi eh bien il fait ce qu'il
veut
moi ce qui me plaît chez booba c'est ce
qui fait ce qu'il veut s'en prend
d'attention à ce qu'on attend de lui
certaines choses attendent lui qui soit
plutôt comme ceci ou comme cela il a
jamais fait ça seulement ce qu'il a
envie de faire et même si c'est une
erreur
il fait seulement ce qu'il a envie de
faire et ces sectes qui sait ce qui est
bien parce que silva écoutez moi ce
qu'on m'avait dit au sujet de ma vie
j'aurai ni fait de la musique n'y serait
venu que tpm penny j'aurais unis
seraient sortis valérie ni en fait moi
je le suis je le suis dans cette logique
la queue au moins il fait ce qu'il veut
faire et comme il a envie de le faire et
comme il veut questionner dakarois moi
je dis qu'il bluffe
non moi je bluffe c'était du bluff non
non c'était un peu le sait rien de ce
vote dans le plat c'est un porno c'est
important et pour filtrer je l'aimais
avant qu'il aille en prison et je
l'aimerai et je laime maintenant après
aussi à oui alors vous en pensez quoi
est ce que vous êtes pour ou est ce
qu'on vous dit tu devrais contrées peu
curieusement je suis pour mais moi je
suis pour que ça se passe en france au
pied avec lui parce que pourquoi là mais
que ce parce qu'ils sont maurice tomi
neurones et donc ça peut ça on adore la
boxe ce rêve ou pas et moi c'est vrai
que mine de rien ce que tu m'avais dit
au départ quand on s'appelait ségou va
aussi ils voulaient voilà défendre les
valeurs aussi de la boxe ici dit voilà
enfin combats en boxe lui contre moi au
moins comme ça après voilà c'est serré
mais c'est un combat aussi vous la
proposer l'octogone à ces jeux proposés
pièces et ça exactement elle a dit
octogone sans règle pas d'art beach de
morts étaient à ajouter aucun gilles moi
je suis contre le combat au nom du
devoir selon moi d'exemplarité que vous
avez passé elle a 10 ans à la subvenir
elle m'a dit mais vous recevez une star
incroyable les enfants vous adore et je
trouve que votre musique est formidable
et c'est pas le bon exemple
selon moi ce combat c'est pas une bonne
idée
ce couac hockey ce cas que j'arrive à
être un exemple c'est vrai tu t'en fous
de ça je suis enragé pas je n'ai pas
rêvé d'être artiste je vis ma vie je
donne
j'assume les conséquences c'est moi qui
suis allé en prison c'est pas les gens
mais il ya des gens qui te dis ouais
j'aurais un exemple ça qu'est-ce que tu
réponds quoi la tuer mais je trouve
qu'un combat de boxe vois pas je vois
passionne alors un combat de boxe moi je
suis un peu comme franchement pas de ce
monde fait de la pub pas mort d'homme
moi je préfère toujours dit oui c'est un
mauvais exemple
voilà orly c'est un mauvais exemple on
est d'accord mais voilà il a dit non et
si un mauvais exemple
moi quand on tousse ap je suis d'accord
avec lui mais non un combat de boxe
voilà c'est au contraire est-ce que ça
mettrait fin à ce feuilleton entre vos
doigts et c'est ça est ce que une fois
que tout ça sera évacué va vous pourrez
et l'un et l'autre s'il ressort
handicapés ça tu peux pas dire ça il ya
plein de gens handicapés et nous
regardent et handicapées qui c'est vrai
soient bons exemples sont formidables
voilà et haegeli voilà il ya un beau
bouquet mon frère ou là et tu vois que
jackie chan est un gros bisou voilà et
momo c'est mon frère et il est
exceptionnel il est bien au dessus de
moi et bien au-dessus de nous on ne peut
pas dire ça oui je trouve que le seul
intérêt de ce combat évidemment tu as
raison c'est pas une belle image mais si
vous reverser tous les bénéfices à des
associations à ce nom après après google
one pass et de la communication show
d'oppression euros beaucoup de personnes
se demandent est-ce que c'est pas que de
la communication
non non c'est une vraie haine tu sais
pas dire voilà c'est une brent pour ça
que vous prenez à la rigolade mais
moulin à la rigolade
non parce que sa box à la loyale jean
michel jarre michel moi je suis moi je
suis pour un vrai match que ce soit
anglais de jouer même s'ils ont envie de
faire la mema c'est leurs problèmes sans
fin se met même à zéro tracas zéro
[Rires]
je pense pas du tout frustré après les
meilleurs amis du mois je pense qu'il
serait toujours est nommé au moins alors
un corps et gagner et ça change quand
même un peu les donnes du problème voilà
étions pas mal mais on préfère ce sont
six ans et moi quelle place va perdre
non en revanche au concours d'éloquence
allemagne c'est pas stéphane bern vous
possédez une ferro vont pas te raconter
un coût de l'ensemble sur la gueule ben
ya pas mal de gens qui râlent je te dis
sur ce que tu viens de dire du genre sur
sur le handicap
je sais que voilà je sais pas ce que ce
que tu alors des parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui réagissent
la chine chez le derrière de file voilà
c'est vrai que bon voilà je pense que ta
ta ta c'est parce que tu voulais dire en
fait sur dans le cas et je parle pas de
juin voila voila c'était voilà c'était
nos unes voilà une attaque contre c'est
peu c'est pas une attaque retrouvée à
une personne handicapée il ya des jolies
moi je suis bien placé pour le savoir et
on est au contact
oui jour de personnes handicapées qui
qui valent beaucoup plus vous avez vu
boube avec sa fille
c'est un mec qui subit une mauvaise est
terrible oui réussit non mais dans la
rue c'est fantastique c'est vrai ça
c'est un bon gars on sait que c'est un
bon gars pour ça vous voulez poser une
question si c'était comme ça chez booba
je reconnaisse et athènes
on a des dénominateurs communs il ya
quelques ressemble de blousons noirs
provocateur avant tout et je pense qu'il
admire beaucoup les gens qui font pas
moi qui le fais vocation tous les âges
tués à l'âge que j'ai assez atypique et
tu es comme son champion qui s'appelle
francky vincent
parce qu'à mes débuts en oeuvre j'ai
quand j'ai décidé je
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais quand je voulais chanter c'est que
j'ai des problèmes avec les parents
proches mes amis j'ai rien lâché geria
les chiens lâchés voilà rien laisser
derrière toi a jamais rien laisser dire
et là